thank you so much I'm so excited I know
right so we're celebrating these make a
lot of noise so now we're done with them
there we go but for all you fans who are
tuning in right now start sending in
your questions and comments from Vanessa
I've already picked a few comments that
she's going to be reading and plus we
have we have a special exclusive sneak
peek clip from tonight's episode that
you guys do not want to miss because
spoiler alert Johnny Ed's hair looks
amazing
without the beanie yes this is like a
rare gift yeah it's like an animal out
in the wild and I love it
I'm so excited that you're on right now
this is our first time meeting you know
and I've been I've been watching all
like all your segments and I'm like I
want to be on there so finally gonna
happen uh we made it happen
your hair looks even more amazing in
person than it does on TV how are you
liking the pink locks I love it like I'm
literally sporting it to like all my
photo shoots and events now like you're
liking the Tony look aren't you I'm like
are you saying I should change it looks
so good now do you have to keep
reapplying it yeah well it's a wash up
okay so last like five day washes so
yeah looks good and I'm getting some
Tony like topaz vibes from you right now
this is my this is me Vanessa I go to
outfit going out but I think a leather
jacket right now that's making me look
super Tony when I was talking with
Ashley Marie recently on set she's like
I'm bummed because like I can never wear
leopard anymore cuz everyone's like
Josie really yeah I could I could
definitely see that it's funny because I
thought going out for Halloween being a
leopard everyone be like oh you're a
leopard great yeah the amount of people
that came up to me and said oh you're
Josie in the Pussycats I was like I'm a
leopard I was trying to be an animal I
mean so I could see why that's happening
guys what has it been like for you
joining the Riverdale world it's been
amazing it's been crazy everybody has
been so nice the cast is amazing
they've welcomed me in mhm it's always
nerve-wracking joining a cast especially
cuz you guys shoot up in Vancouver
isolated exactly one of my best friends
Madalena by Sheryl Lawson love her
already on the show and she's welcomed
me and gave me a tour sick guys my best
friends here yeah
welcome her in and that it was great so
like I you know I feel like I have like
you know mean that really so I love
being there oh so it's like a second
home to exactly um but we had Mads on
recently and I adore her so much
and she was she and I were talking about
some things that we'll be getting to
show knee but I think we should take a
look at some fan comments so I pulled
some comments for us from our suite
order secrets episode that was all about
chapter 19 death Proof and that was when
Toni revealed to Jughead that she's
actually bisexual yes now first of all
when you found out that they were gonna
be confirming that because it was a
rumor of the Archie comics what was your
reaction when when Roberto told you that
news well actually I found out from I
think it was the article that you Pro
when you first learned that Vanessa
Morgan was playing Tony topes I wrote
that yeah so yeah so I actually learned
from your articles because I wasn't told
when I was like being cast that she was
gonna be bisexual and then I found that
out I was like great love it um so I'm
just happy that you know that they're
following through that and a lot of fans
loved it so much so first comment right
now is gonna be from taya 808 and she
said honestly though I'm such a big fan
of Vanessa / Tony overall especially
since she's in one of my all-time
favorite childhood TV shows my
babysitter's a vampire so I'm honestly
kind of sad she isn't was Jughead but
you do you boo I was like okay thank you
Bill she also added in her hisses and
kisses and she gave a kiss to your hair
saying Toni's freaking hair is beautiful
I agree I agree thank you I love that
beginning so many people messaged me
saying I can't stop seeing Sara like
you'll always be a vampire to me when I
see Toni vampire snakes I kind of go
hand in hand of you know my theory is
it's like cool after that proof any of
anybody who's similar to his vampire
there was an explosion at the end of the
season finale who my theory is maybe she
just you know reincarnated herself as
Toni completely the game I like that
still in the same universe yes but you
know I was talking to Madeline mhm
and so many fans out there have this
vibe that they're getting between Cheryl
and Tony you have a couple of fan
comments what are they saying about that
okay
Zachary Vargas if Tony is bi is there a
way for her to be with Cheryl the girl
needs love and I would choose bridge
here Josie for her but they look like
they might have something going on okay
um I agree with you Cheryl needs love
Cheryl like how much can one girl takes
you know later I mean we'll see what the
writers have in store I don't know
what's gonna happen but you know I'm for
it laddy and I loved what this person
said green Lac said haha the flirty look
that Tony gave to Cheryl in the drag
moment oh the amount of people that
reposted that like when I was doing it I
wasn't even like I didn't even know the
people were gonna screenshot and do that
I just thought I thought it was like you
know we're too confident girls are
walking by I was like I usually do that
like like who do you think you are
yeah anyway but they took that one look
and you don't ran with it and you know
the the funniest one that I saw was like
Tony looking at Madol Tony looking at
Cheryl like she's like a full-course
Thanksgiving like meal Oh like that I
was like okay great how do you think
they would be as a couple you know what
I think they would be a great couple um
you know they're there to like you know
bossy you know girls strong independent
I think they could be like a little
power couple okay I like that
stir up stir up some chaos um but you
know who knows
have you figured out what you want the
potential ship name to be cuz it's still
a little bit in flux right now I've
heard Shoni I've heard Terrell okay yeah
Johnny for Terrell I've heard yeah sure
Oni sure Oni
okay alright I don't know I feel about
sure Oh me
so many fans are saying Joanie okay now
are we doing that with the church like
show you know what I ya know it's yummy
it should be so much
it should be yeah yeah so they write it
like Choni but we're gonna pronounce it
like Shoni Shoni all right this is it
you heard it here on Sweetwater speakers
hi my favorite last comment that we're
going to include with Sofia Rosa
almstrom when on this amazing rant
saying to all the absolutely insane
bug-head shippers who hated on Tony
before even learning the slightest thing
about her I really hope this episode
taught them something because she was
the only one acting someone saying
kisses to her for acting responsible and
I thought that was really sweet because
unfortunately you have been getting a
little bit of social media backlash and
when I say a little bit I mean floods
and floods of tweets yeah what has that
been like for you is that hard um I
think maybe the first time I saw it it
was a little bit hard um you know I the
fandom is so strong yeah everybody off
and I think that's just shows how
passionate the fans were so the end of
the day I was brought in no matter what
actors they hired yeah you know what I
mean for you know coming in between and
away between a popular couple you're
gonna get some backlash um I don't think
that Tony um broke up Buckhead I think
it was the black hood I agree I um you
know people were saying you know okay
but it was a black card and I think it's
one of those things you know Buckhead
and Tony 14:8 like our teenagers yeah
right so the hormones are horrible to
had a rough day together and they think
that yes you know and then but to see
Tony's defense yes they were on a break
and I didn't wanna break on a break and
I came you know you're sitting with a
cute guy you know emotions are high and
you're like I'm sure there are plenty of
girls out there who would love to kiss
Cole Sprouse so so you know I you know
it is what it is and then I think Tony
realized you know he's not over his
girlfriend they're in love yes and I'm
you know more into girls anyways so
let's just do friends for good as
friends I love that I love that do you
feel a little bit of pressure to
represent the LGBTQ community in a
certain way you know if you see there is
it a bit of pressure because not you
know being bisexual characters aren't
represented as often which they you know
they should be so I just hope I do a
good job that's the really the only
stress that I have with that um I really
just want to do a good job and represent
that well I know Tony be getting the
love interest the season I know you guys
are on up
so I was like 14 now so yeah happened I
you know I think Tony deserves some love
yes I you know I I hope so
I can't say much but I definitely think
that that would be nice with Tony I
agree I agree I do want to get your
thoughts really quick we're gonna get to
the exclusive sneak peek clip from
tonight's episode very soon but if you
guys will recall in last week's episode
we discovered that Cheryl has got a
little bit of a crush on Josie right now
what are your thoughts just as
Madeline's best friend about that
storyline I mean I I think it's uh you
know for me I didn't I didn't know they
were gonna go that direction but you
know I I love both those characters I
like watching it ya know what I mean
um so that was like juicy to watch I did
I did not know that they were gonna do
that
make sure all get love find you yeah
keep my fingers crossed
Mario um so right now we actually have a
special sneak-peek clip run tonight's
episode and we'll give you a little bit
of a setup for it so FPS out of jail
yeah the serpent a serpent he is back
and there's a really sweet scene where
he and Jughead are bonding they're
having a motorcycle-riding bonding sesh
take a look at it right now and then you
and I would be discussing what happens
in it
things got ugly when you were away I
asked myself every day what you would do
she were here as penny bothered you
figure she's the one in grease my wheels
I did a job for what kind of job it's a
one-time thing sure got it best not to
ask too many questions
we're squared away sure good you know
when I was 16 my old man kicked me out
and told me to go to hell instead I
joined the serpent's and then the army
and then back again I don't want that
life from your joke I want you to go to
college get out of this godforsaken town
I ran the gauntlet I fought with the
Serpent's and for them I have to stay I
want to stay but I need your blessing
he's promise me you'll keep writing and
will I do every day
Riverdale all-new episode tonight at
8:17 so cute how great Cole's hair look
on the beam yeah I was when I first
watched the episode I was staring I was
like why does something look so
different it's his hair is yours seems
so operators like blowing they should do
that more often yeah they should but
then just like how they rarely let
Betty's ponytail down yeah which oh my
goodness
Toni's comment about the ponytail I know
I'm at a conference I got for that one
and you know what Tony actually like you
know playing her I thought it was like a
funny thing yeah we're like how dare you
my girlfriend
one also if you're wearing your hair the
same thing every day and plus I Lily
herself has told me she would like to
let her hair down more because the
ponytail actually hurts yeah I can
imagine it's so tight all the time you
know like a hobby nice and again for
them but I went in that clip that
Jughead was saying like no he likes the
serpent's like he wants to stay in it
like don't you plaid I love that we're
all a family yeah Shepard's don't shed
their skin no they don't they also have
some very interesting traditions what
can you tease we are gonna be seeing a
lot more from the Serpent's in tonight's
episode what can you tease for the fans
out there what can I teach I mean um
you're gonna see a very interesting
awesome juicy side of Betty tonight you
will and what's so fun is that on our
Sweetwater secrets after-show you will
be hearing from the lovely Vanessa
talking about the most insane
mind-blowing moment from tonight's
episode so get excited and check back
for that because you guys do not want to
miss it
you guys are sending in so many great
comments right now Lauren the girl next
door says do you know who the black hood
is I don't really know and I've heard
people say they know who it is and I'm
like I have so much fun though I
literally don't know who the bucket is
do you ever do you get the full scripts
or do you sometimes only just got your
scenes no I get the full screen okay but
you know I still don't know
the black card is but we only get our
episode sometimes even a couple days
before filming the episode okay um but I
want to know you know I want to know
more about Tony's home life and her
family is that something that we could
possibly be exploring I have no idea so
I just made I definitely think that
you're going to see a little bit of her
home life coming up she's mentioned her
uncle but she's mentioned but like if
you remember in that episode I say like
I'm basically hopping from house to
house until my uncle's stop stalking me
yeah yeah
so I don't personally I have enough shot
over the writers I don't think that I
have like parents yeah um well who knows
what the situation is if they're you
know not in my life
but I think that you're gonna meet
definitely a family member that might
give you some insight into her life
interesting okay hmm
I'm trying to figure out is it someone
that we've met before
no okay I didn't even met before fresh
face I think she comes from a little of
a hard life oh that's like that's my
theory on Tony okay I think so too I
think that she she's like puts up a
front of it yeah tough because I think
she's had to be she's a badass I think
she's really cool whenever you put on
that serpent jacket do you feel a little
bit more like alright one person I do I
feel so badass I feel like I could walk
in like the worst area of town you know
as myself whenever I'm wearing it you
already mean I'm like where's my gang
members no we're sweet pea rudia we're
sleeping but the first time actually
putting on like I took the jacket and
put on in medicine
literally was in my head I should have
played it while I was putting because
you know I would saw the last episode
and then I watched it right before
starting it was so in my head so I was
like uh yeah Cece says if jugg leaves
the serpents for Betty I will cry with a
bunch of cry emojis and snake emojis
interesting I would - yeah I can do both
you can do both it's riverdale anything
is anything wrong what is something that
is coming up that you're excited for
to see your like I can't even tease
anything I I know that I'm excited
because next week's episode is the
Christmas episode oh yes yeah say you've
seen it I have seen I have seen it I was
that was actually so you guys have
actually been asking spoiler alert that
was the episode that I was on set more
so oh so you're on Tiffani I was on set
for the Christmas episode I was in pops
and it was covered in Christmas
decorations and we actually had to take
them down so that it looked like generic
spot background in the background of it
I was in the white worm like ants
outside so when we found that hi misty
oh okay I'll see you soon outside I will
have to come the south side
how cool is the white worm though it had
there been any like things that you
found on Seth that you're like oh my
gosh this is nuts
I've actually stolen something from the
white worm it was like a little mini toy
snakes that's I know that sounds so
random no it's fine yeah but I was a
snake for Halloween I'm gonna take some
of the snakes oh I've stolen that but
there's like a weird Medusa statue very
fitting yeah yeah that in the white worm
and there's really cool snake signs my
character works in a bar which I was
watching that in tonight's episode I'm
like is that legal
yes myself the same thing but I mean you
know it's all serpents in there anything
goes they make their own laws yeah well
thank you so much for joining me for a
special Alive episode of sweet water
secret so thank you all so much for
tuning in remember that anything that
the characters do be nice to the actors
that play them give them love on social
media so that we can keep the Riverdale
fandom a nice positive place yes you
guys be sure to tune in to Sweetwater
secrets after you watch tonight's
episode chapter 21 house of the devil
for exclusive information from this
lovely lady about the scene that
everyone's going to be talking about
thank you very much for tuning in bye
guys
you